These are the things I prep
to make my week just a little bit easier.
This week I started off by making some Cheez its.
I combined all of my ingredients
and then let the dough rest in the fridge.
My bananas weren't as ripe as I wanted them,
so I popped them in the oven to ripen
and then got started on making a chocolate banana bread
this week. Usually make a loaf a week
because it's so easy and quick to make
and everyone loves it.
Then I boiled my chickpeas
for the hummus I was gonna make later
while I prepped a cucumber and herb salad.
I chopped all my ingredients really fine,
added some feta,
and did a really classic olive oil lemon vinaigrette.
This goes well on everything.
Then I moved on to making Moroccan meatballs.
For the protein
I used some ground beef.
And do not forget to put cinnamon in your meatballs.
I promise it's so good.
I pulled my cheese a dough out of the fridge
and sliced it into little squares or rectangles.
Then I put holes in them,
pop them in the oven,
and once they were done
I let them cool while I made my hummus.
I went for a cilantro garlic hummus
this time around.
My husband wanted different types of proteins prepped,
so I made a quick teriyaki sauce
to make teriyaki chicken.
I let that thicken up on the stove
while I sliced up some apples.
For my kids,
and also some broccoli
just to have it handy.
And then it was time to put everything away.
I put away my hummus and moved on to my salad.
I like making smaller quantities of things
just because I get over the flavors really quickly.
Put away my Cheez its,
then moved on to my broccoli and apples.
I also put some lemon juice on my apples
to keep them from Browning.
My teriyaki chicken
and that same morning
I started making some Korean shredded beef
in my crock pot,
so I put that away as well.
Since that was done.
Is so versatile.
I put it on sandwiches,
rice, tortillas,
anything. And that wraps up my meal prep for this week.
I don't put my banana bread in a separate container
because it's usually gone in two to three days anyways.